but I noticed you have a tattoo and we
have a thing going
I have 17 yeah I don't have tattoos I
have stretch marks I have those too
depending on how I move like a cheetah
figures very cool the characters look
different when I shift I have a couple
tattoos that are super suspect at this
point right right right so they look
different well what about that guy okay
getting my name on I know he's gonna
regret it but what's your dessert what
does Joe chance get to eat but he has so
many tattoos and he didn't ask you can
we bring that up when he comes back he
actually he yeah right he recognized me
but he confused me for being someone
else no sighing that person's name that
happens to me all the time you think
seriously I have been asked so many
times like or they'll be like oh my gosh
I love your song so small and I'm like I
don't even know what that is what is it
and then I'll find out it's Carrie
Underwood and I'm like yeah I'm just
saying it's real different though I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this